welcome to this video yeah this is a
game against pon pon coupon or coupon
from Japan if you wonder why the rating
is coming down I had a game which I
simply don't upload any more i had a
game where i'm lost with Bishop and pawn
against Bishop and pawn where you could
just shuffle the pieces for 30 moves and
then I lost all time I don't upload
those games anymore i think it's it's
simply not chess so I am I don't I don't
really think it's any use so um once in
a while my rating will plummet because I
don't upload those games anymore so um
do we have here a hedgehog I had a lot
of a shock he's not taking um yeah which
allows white to play d5 normally
considered to be quite good for what if
he manages to do that an interesting
point is if why it takes if black takes
on on d5 then sometimes is the move
Knight to h4 I'm not one hundred percent
sure if I should do that here or just
play the pawn recapture yeah I just
recapture with the pawn or not okay
where this is also a good move it uses
this pin intending maybe two to put earn
a piece on d5 trying to to make that
work 95 95 Bishop g5 Bishop do you have
25 rookie to may be possible
it's no big technical trick to make that
work can I go nitey 30 sd4 then move
Bishop both when we 7s hanging I still
wonder about this this line I don't know
Knight takes bishop takes Bishop takes
Queen takes rookie too hmm the whole
thing looks like there might be
something certainly some compensation
maybe I'm I should just play that and
see what happens now it's not even
considering this yeah now I can just
take end and then better them better
having them the whole on d5 to exploit
like this Queen d3 and 95 leading to a
situation where I'm fighting with this
eternal night against the bishop on g7
should g 7i I still need to spend and
move on Ruby one ok although I can just
I can just go down I really don't want
them to take them on a one yeah okay I
don't mind trade so that's that's clear
I let him take maybe
yeah right of course has a great
position with the 95 the question is
however how to really get ahead and
maybe I should have taken out i was i
was just thinking maybe you can play at
five intending after the capture to take
with the pawn maybe yeah yeah i should
have taken I should have taken my cell
phone your phone not a big problem but
it would be more comfortable to have the
Queen's off and not get a pawn to e4 and
now he's taking anyway ok I would like
to play rook A two and A five I'm aiming
for that
what are you going to do one a5 b5 and
then let's know it's still good for what
I don't think b5 takes e4 I mean this is
really still good and if I manage to
give them a weakness on the B file and
I'm entering here with with the rook
then it should be really excellent okay
this means there's no new weakness on
them on the a farm the a pawn how to
best put pressure on this you might play
rook b7 okay maybe I should just
prophylactically prevent that and then
look d 2 a 2 or a g 1 a 1 something like
that
yum F form now therefore it's not yet a
serious counterplay if he prepares it i
might play a for myself okay oh here why
this is nice I know I know should also
get the King involved King to d3 you
would be nice of course short-term
Brooke a5 takes a seven is coming the
knight on d5 is nicely preventing the
the black rook from going to e7 I will
just take the pawn him the only recount
of plywood bf4 but I'm on that gfgf
night f4 can grab this
no I'm not just getting the pawn I'm
also entering here on the seventh rank
so keeping in keeping control check
which is of course very important not
giving giving him any sort of counter
play yeah look is seven now would be a
rook trade it's okay okay but anything
anything better maybe look at this app
now just asking how to protect this
rookie six is possible but very passive
move time morning let's look cannot
approach so I can go F 3 mm or should I
play f3 f3 okay I'm not sure it all is
quite nice
there is no direct urban unfortunately
at least I don't see it and now we can
just come in here sure this was bad
check check yeah getting to this rook
endgame it it wasn't exactly my dream
scenario but it's a it's still very good
now cannot keep the Kings side now check
check check check check and it was still
very bad badly played from me
technically I mean you really shouldn't
have forgotten that form black forfeits
on time me let me check this I mean
charity it is really like total
domination maybe I should just play wiki
seven and exchanged looks somehow it
feels wrong to exchange rooks but it's
probably just very easy just get the
rooks off and and play the this the
minor piece end game which is a very
easy win yeah this is better just get
the rooks off it's easier to play maybe
not better a bit easier to play I should
have played f3 before also check Jackie
need to was stupid and around here i
don't know i think he can just not take
if he does not take i don't know how to
win this really don't one drop back and
how do i win
check can go here it's probably nothing
I really miss played that quite
considerably yeah around here think this
was okay in good strategical game check
and I just need to exchange books it's
easier by farm on yeah just to just play
it play better here starting with
playing every you should start off this
is also better probably and maybe maybe
go here I don't know something like that
is is probably probably just better I
allowed him far too much cotton and I
gave up give up Tempe and I King you to
check and back not not really great okay
but we at the end yeah thanks for
watching